I haven't do the fish ah I got rid of  them just figured it was for the best I  couldn't get into it you were employed  at the homecoming transitional support  center how do you feel happy what we're  seeking here is information nation what  were your duties there I don't know you  don't know I know why I'm here I want to  be in compliance with all this  compliance have you ever forgotten  something something big  you think just a place where they want  to help us out we're here to help them  we can leave whatever we want this is  about your future  I should think very carefully  I could take care of them if you want  look what did she know  you're worried aren't you yes I am  you